-Our next guest has her comedy
special "The Hustler"
premiering March 9th on YouTube.
Please welcome the very funny
Kelsey Cook.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow, hi, thank you so much.
It's great to be here.
I am from Spokane, Washington,
originally,
and I've been on tour a lot
the past year.
And sometimes people go,
"You ever get scared to perform
in dangerous places
like New York City?"
I'm like, "Spokane is the meth
capital of America."
Okay? I am the danger.
[ Laughter ]
Spokane is rough.
Last time I was home, I got an
Uber driver named Bones.
[ Laughter ]
And he looked like a Bones.
I cancelled the ride
immediately, of course.
I'm not going to get into a car
with my ex.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What a crazy name.
Bones must get 200 ride
cancellations an hour.
I don't even think
he owns a car.
I think he just sits in bed and
collects a $5 cancellation fee.
[ Laughter ]
Every 30 seconds.
He's probably a millionaire.
I need to make a driving profile
with a fake photo
and say my name is Stabs.
[ Laughter ]
I'd like a new laptop.
I'm in a new relationship,
and we had that conversation
about labels
because I felt ready to be
called boyfriend and girlfriend.
And he goes, "You know, being in
my 40s, I feel like
I'm a little old to be called
somebody's boyfriend.
But if you call me
your man friend,
that sounds like I've committed
sex crimes."
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, "Alright, well,
what are you going to call me?"
And he goes, "I'll just be like,
'This is my lady.'"
I was like,
"Well, that feels like
we're at a renaissance fair."
[ Light laughter ]
And I can't use the equivalent
of that.
I can't be like, "Mom, Dad,
I'd like you to meet my lord."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ugh.
And he's also a comedian.
And I wasn't much of a jealous
girlfriend in my 20s.
And then some switch flipped
in my 30s.
And now when I see somebody hit
on the person I'm with,
I just feel myself animorph into
the cast of "Jersey Shore."
[ Laughter ]
I am ready to brawl.
And he does get hit on.
When he walks on stage,
women whistle at him.
And at comedy clubs, there's
usually a security guard
in the back to kick people out
in case they heckle.
So at his shows, I've just
started to stand
next to the security guard.
And if I see a woman laughing
too hard at one of his jokes,
I just walk up and I'm like,
"Hey, I'm going to have to ask
you to leave."
[ Laughter ]
"He's my favorite comedian."
Well, he's my lord, so beat it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Scoot.
The last time I did "The Tonight
Show," I mentioned that
my entire family and I are
actually
world champion foosball players.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, thank you.
But what's fun for me,
since nobody suspects that
I'm a pro foosball player,
I love to hustle people.
Right? And I usually play
against other comedians
on my foosball web series.
But we did this special episode
where I went undercover in Vegas
and hustled drunk dudes
on the Vegas Strip.
[ Laughter ]
So, I wore this low-cut top.
I talked in the worst voice.
And my camera crew and I would
go up to groups of guys.
And I'd go, [High-pitched voice]
"Hi, my name is Kelsey
and I have this web series
where I do things
that I've never done before
for the first time."
[ Laughter ]
"It's called 'Pop My Cherry.'"
"Silly. So, I've never played
foosball before.
And we just found this table
and I was just wondering if you
guys wanted to play me."
[ Normal voice ]
Every group of guys was like,
"Hell yeah, lady, let's go.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I'll play you right now."
And so I would play the first
game terribly on purpose.
I would giggle a bunch,
spin the rods a lot.
Really build up
their confidence.
And then I'd go, "Okay, so, I
think I have the hang of it now.
And this is Vegas, so we should
play for money."
[ Laughter ]
And every guy would put their
whole wallet on the table.
[ Laughter ]
They'd hand me the ball and go,
"Here, you can serve first."
And that's when I pull out
my foosball grip glove.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I've never done cocaine,
but I would assume
it's a similar rush.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, thank you,
I'm Kelsey Cook.
Thanks for having me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on! Thank you so much.
That's how you do it.
Kelsey Cook.
"The Hustler" will be available
March 9th on YouTube.
We'll be right back, everybody.
Come on back.